c'était attendu par de nombreux français
les cafés bars et restaurants sont enfin
autorisés à rouvrir complètement en zone
verte dès demain et partiellement en
ile-de-france en guyane et à mayotte
dans ces trois territoires seuls les
terrasses pourront accueillir des
clients un dispositif qui satisfait ce
restaurateur parisien
je pense que oui ça va un peu nous aider
justement avec la vente à emporter si on
arrive à gérer les deux avant la
terrasse que sa vente à emporter ça nous
aide parce que dresser une visibilité de
fait d'être ouvert
ça permet de montrer qu'on existe encore
dans beaucoup de bars et de restaurants
à paris il ya des habitués et les
habitués là on a vu depuis un mois et ça
va continuer vraiment nous soutenir donc
ils seront là donc je pense qu'en fait
vu le peu de tables qu'on aura en
terrasse on sera toujours plein une
disparité qui s'appliquera aussi aux
hébergements touristiques qui rouvriront
dès le 2 juin en zone verte mais pas
avant le 22 du mois en zone orange même
différence pour les piscines salles de
sport parc de loisirs salle de spectacle
et pour les théâtres
autre bonne nouvelle pour le tourisme
plages lacs et musées seront dans leur
ensemble accessible au public dès demain
pour les professionnels du secteur
l'heure est au soulagement même si cette
réouverture dans des conditions
sanitaires strictes chamboule de
nombreux établissements donc de ce côté
là c'est la partie sommes donc les
jeunes prendront part cette porte et
sortir ou par celle ci manquera pas de
croisement de personnes et en plus on va
rajouter du distributeur de savon à
chacune et chacun afin qu est également
à l'intérieur des douches par ailleurs
les déplacements des français ne seront
plus limités
la barrière des 100 km et enlever les
déplacements entre métropole et outre
mer reste toutefois conditionnée à des
motifs impérieux
enfin les déplacements hors de france
sont pour l'instant impossible
prochain étape du déconfinement le 22
juin